Welcome to our next next day of Workshop
so today's Wednesday and we have our
first Speaker
he will tell us about learning and
several new directors
thank you for coming this very early
morning talk so today I'm going to today
I'm going to talk about the
relationships between running and
pseudo-random generators computable in
constant part of that and this stock is
based on joint work with you
so in this Workshop we have already seen
or maybe we will see many beautiful
relationships between learning and
student randomness
so generally speaking learning lovely
speaking learning is a task to find
hidden information hidden information in
the observed data by contrast student
Randomness is so pseudonym studying is a
string indistinguishable from a true
relational story but generated from a
very short City
so now so if we consider this learner as
an adversary that tries to distinguish
this is random string and if we
regarding information the learner tries
to learn as a randomly to generate
pseudonym string then these two goals
say kind of opposite things so that's
why in a certain reason maybe we cannot
hope for both simultaneous
then the desirable situation here is to
guarantee is at least one of efficient
runs or security
and this year's a winning object
and this question is refreshed so
whether we can obtain the equivalence
result between hardness burning and the
existence of pseudo-random generator
and so in general case fortunately the
answer is yes
so particularly One Direction from a
pseudo-randomness to harness running
dates back the very first paper by
variant in computational learning series
the other direction is by a
the other direction is by imperative and
brown Frost and Ripton and many other
Dropbox and they so to show the opposite
direction they consider they often
consider average case variant balances
like
particularly in the previous about dfka
they proposed a very natural average gas
volume to Parkland so now I explain this
model
so the target of learning is a concept
class as just usual background and which
is defined as a subset of golient
function here
and in this uh average case variant so
we consider two distribution the first
one is distribution of a functions
integrals so precisely speaking so this
is a distribution of a representation of
functions in the class
and the second distribution is example
usually called example distribution this
is a distribution of a input function in
and so in this average case running
model so we consider weak running for
Class C platform so the runner is given
a sample set so input output pairs for
all target functions that run authorized
to learn where this target function is
selected according to this distribution
f
and each input to the Target function
this is usually called example is
circulate according to this example
distribution
and this Runner is also given an
unlabeled data challenge
and this challenge is also selected
according to the same example
distribution and the task is to find the
level of this chart
with the non-negative probability better
than randomness
and so I mentioned that so we usually
call this m the amount of samples the
runner requires as a sample complexity
and in this model we can characterize
the existence of pseudo and object so
the pseudo-random existence generator is
characterized by others gets hardness of
weak learning in this model for some
polynomial computable Class C with
respect to sample distribution the F and
B so we consider very general learning
setting then we can calculate
ingredients of PPT
okay great
then okay let's move on to next question
learning a simple class versus
pseudo-random data computable in simple
cross
actually this question is motivated from
both type
so from one side so from the existence
of students
it's usually demonstrated as a
cryptographic hardware to identify the
capability of efficient learning
and so I will explain later the recent
work in this research Direction and the
other direction
from harness regarding to pseudonym
generator in computer computable in
simple class is motivated by a
efficiently performable cryptography but
uh food security is based on countless
assumption learning particularly in BFK
so this motivation is also mentioned and
they proposed one candidate for
pseudo-random generator computable in
policies DNS based on some other
educational design
and in this talk in this work we
consider one of the simplest cases in
pseudo-random generator part so we
consider the relationships between a
average case holderness learning and the
existence of polynomial storage is to
the random generator computable and c0
in short pprg and CG what is this
princess so etiosis
looks like this so if this is random
generator so it is given a bit random
student then it storage is it polynomial
energy
but Point here is so this print must be
computable in nc0s it means that each
suit random bit only depends on constant
number of random system
and so this spring team is very
important for several elements of
applications
and the point here is so but
constructing ppology in nc0 is
relatively harder than constructing
other cryptographic explained to be
analysis in the sense that so we do not
have any known construction based on the
celebrated work or randomized angle
because to apply randomized encoding we
need additional Randomness and of course
the same amount of Randomness it will be
outputed but it drastically decreases
the storage of pseudonym so that's why
based on random address we do not have
any
it is so this is a generator uh
specified so fixed predicate Peak and
input outputs are input output
connections and it defines some
generator so we have a random stick and
for each input output connection we look
at the corresponding path and we apply
this fixed rate
and so previously you know uh candidates
for pplc00 follows this framework with
good choice of fixed by political p and
input output yes
[Music]
the
reduce the compressor need additional
products
and we enclose out of
controllers
but so
if we add a additional randomness yeah
and of course the same amount of
randomly output but this additional
Randomness the decreasing storage
so yeah even if the original student
understand that for example foreign
but
and I also uh want to mention that so
when we consider a pseudonym generator
intensity it is standard to consider
some reaction relaxed requirements
correction on pprd and syndrome so
difference between correction pptc and
the season and standard pplds just so in
correction PPT and this is a week
consider that initialization step the
description of the generator is selected
According to some genetic generators so
by using a public random Ness but we do
not care about this complexity so this D
might be not compatible in any season
but the automated generator must be
computable in anesthesis
and so we consider this type of agenda
because yeah this is relatively easier
than it's easier to construction yeah
fixed pplz analysis but it does not
affect the application research
expensive
if you need the good and balance
expanders for such a local prgs
even if you pick a collection
they just make the problem go away I
mean there is the workplace show how to
fix subject standards but my question is
technically do you care about some
Universal polynomial failure probability
or you don't care about it but
sorry I'm just saying that there's such
a prg necessitates a good unbalanced
expanders which we don't have explicit
constructions
this is one reason why
it was abundant and with inverse column
and probability Independence in prg
because it doesn't have the necessary
expansion
so is this an issue or lose
some definition of the
distinguished so we come to this we take
into account the randomness
constructions
so that's why if
we say something which expander with the
notes non-negative Maybe
easy distinguished because image
positive community
really specifically notice
it makes it so you just assume that the
subject election exists and that's it
we need to
yeah
others in this one we need to
consideration
foreign
start this video
okay and so let's go back to the
relationships
I guess so if this we saved this input
or progression at uniform so uniformly
at random kind of collection and even in
this one may also consider Corrections
okay so let's go back to the topic about
the relationships to learn and so as far
as I know the previously no relationship
between cpts and decision on the run in
case so Only One Direction so if we have
PPT and c0 or some related notion then
we can show Hardline figure out before
very simple across for example or in the
work by Italian body they show that
hardness is running for several
important courses based on the existence
of poly storage
and in this work we consider the exact
relationship so
equally balance between so
characterization result for correction
ptrsense and if you can show this so we
can
so so it enables a new running cell tech
approach to construct pprd and c0 by
using reasonable seemingly correct
harmless Assumption of running
and so by the very well-known
equivalence result between
um
unpredictable and students so some of
you might be so conjecture that so this
primitive is captured by harness of nc0
I think this is really a natural
conjunction but this natural conjecture
seems to be incorrect because in
cryptography so constructing correction
PPR this is nc0 is a central change by
contrast
so running and system it is usually
called running a constant printer it's
very very reliable by using Occam's
razor
so this running part does not hold
unconditionally
then the question so that's why so when
we consider a very raw complexity class
like as a nc0
the dichotomy between running and large
switch to the random generator since 2
become very non-trader then the question
here is still can we obtain the foreign
yes by considering a fixed parameter
attractable sample complexity so in this
work we consider a parameterized setting
of running so we consider the
parameterized concept processing and
parameters of this process of the
distribution and we consider a fpt
sample compressive written like it's by
using some computable function f
but so Point here is in this work we
consider a fpt sample complexity but we
do not consider FPA the time complexion
the time complexity Can Depend parameter
so in other words in this work we
consider the station in which correcting
samples takes much more cost than
consuming computational time and it is
still natural setting for us
but so even if we consider fixed
parameter tractable sample complexity
the problem does not become so easy so
particularly running cases well the K
factor is a function which depends on
only utmost care level so running Kevin
is still learnable with fpt samples so
to characterize PPL DC analysis we seems
to consider the need to consider some
known terrible learning setting
you know what is the equivalent first of
all we have a general relations between
random generator and average cases
and we
obtain the existence of the
capitalization for correction of PPT and
c0 we tune up these three settings
and the concept graph is C is
and the distribution of our functions is
some Parable by a steps the nc0 circuit
and we consider example distribution at
some problem and C Prime
well the meaning of c Prime space is the
harming weight of string in the
supported sustained support
D is bounded by this reciproc
then we can characterize by using this
running setting we can calculate the
existence of pprd and C 0. informally
but technically speaking to characterize
a collection of PPL Design Systems we
also need to consider initialization
step even for this learning setting so
we must technically speaking we need to
consider some problem with shared
randomness the difference is that the
initialization step we select a shared
run public Randomness
and if there's a shared Randomness we
wish shared during the sampling process
and this part just makes it easier to
hold
it makes the Assumption easier to hold
the fixed example distribution so from
the aspect level this is more this to
construct question paper
and this is the first equivalence result
between question paper artists and
season story can you can you help me
understand uh so C is the concept class
F what is f yeah yeah distribution of a
function I mean so distribution over
representation of 6 Plus is 2.0
and these examples
so sorry so I'm generating the samples
by
one of these
objects
so by by using a Dev generate sample so
input parts and by selecting F we can
we can construct labels
so there is a hidden sparse polynomial
and
what are these labels
Computing by what by circuits
I'm confused how F and C relate
Okay so
fpt uh is about what is FTP so the
parameters uh this C and this D and so
this is all of them okay
and can you explain again what is CNF
episode three can you can you can
explain how C and F player role here
okay so effective function uh contained
in this class C so this F search
representation of c space f 2.0 left
okay
okay all right
yes
[Music]
so you mean
the programming business
sorry
just intuition about the learning
problem how should I think
is it hard similar to something I
thought of before but oh yeah first of
all if we read the existence
something you said something except but
so okay it contains very natural but
each month is a very natural running
program it is
a question with a link
to
run into
targeted
so yes it had some connections with
previously we are studying right and the
study poetry this problem is related to
learning parities with noise
yeah it is just related so so we cannot
show direct connection but so maybe
maybe
a natural settings and then I explained
it
is
so in terms of preserving hardness if
the learning problem says
a pprg the compared me hard and
published we know really hard what is
the level of Art Institute okay so the
security rules is just point number so
it made us though in the beginning in
terms of the expansion skin so maybe
extenders
which is known to be good how is this
reflectable today so yeah so maybe it's
a week because you're such a non-travel
construction in this example in search
of example
that's a super basic questions so
maybe intuitively the reason why we
should think you can answer it yes or no
should think that this concept class is
hard to learn is because like like the
gold rate one-way function and
generators like you know randomly
sampling some inputs and then applying
like a star section polynomial to them
like is that sort of the right intuition
here
and you know maybe so you mean so
so yeah
yeah yeah
oh really okay
very consider uh for example this is
based on this framework the predicate to
be different oh it will be okay okay
so and so this is uh
and we can also obtain the same step
transition result for several elements
um
and so yeah I have already yes but this
result was even a super polynomial with
a polynomial security loss so if we
assume a sub exponential average case
how does the weak run we create a sub
exponential secure technology
and so by using this the
so if you specify F and D satisfying
these constraints and if you believe the
harness running then you can construct
personal PPR divs in NCS so it enables a
new running approach to construct
correction PP or digital system but the
weakness of this theorem is yeah this
theorem itself is very general
characterization reader so it does not
specify any F and D so that's why
Finding good candidate for all these FNB
seems really important and interesting
and so but in the original work we
proposed one very natural candidate
Facebook has for this setting right so
running random party decision
yeah in fact this is a really
similar program to the
learning with noise but the difference
is the noise is will be computed by some
other parties but anyway so running
random party this entrance
and so this is the practice so for each
internal node we ask a party or random
subject and each Leaf is labeled by some
random body
and so hardness of this concept this
random function uh seems consistent with
the current memories
and if this program is uniformly so hard
on uniform example distribution over
slice
then it is a secure correction ppld and
system but there is another reason for
importance of studying this problem so
if this problem is even hard from
uniform example distribution
if you still get a very simply
computable uh
a single pplg computable in parity and
season Where We Are
artists
like curious
foreign
you just mean a constant degree
polynomial
yes yes exactly
okay and in this work we've also
considered several related programs so
for example so in the previous
calculation result we consider first we
assume is past the object but what if we
remove this first data and our technique
for showing the equivalence result still
is a dichotomy between running and suit
Organics for example so if
[Music]
systems running system on distribution
example by C if two pointers it's hard
um so we consider General sampler this
direction without positive data then we
can obtain the existence of correct so
we can put in correction on pplj is
computable and constant plus F2
polynomials and if we consider sample of
distribution with shared Randomness we
can characterize this equation
pathologies and we can also obtain the
same result for OC Furious bus from
and the second so
in the previous characterization result
we considered a correction of pp object
but can we obtain the dichotomy between
running and a single pprd computable in
some simple class
the answer is yes by considering okay so
parity incision and so yeah this is
actually equivalent to constant degree
F2 polynomial s and so we can
characterize single pplc computable and
political system based on the average
case hardness brand for degree DF 2.0 or
distribution or sample by a degree D
Prime of 2.0 and we consider uniform
example distribution
and we can also show that so if we
change this uniform example this object
to General some Parable distribution
with shared Randomness so we can also
calculate the existence of Correction of
PPR that is computable in the same class
so in other we can characterize the
difference between single pprg and a
collection of pprds in the class party
and season by using the difference
between the generality of example
distribution in the hardware spot the
uniform distribution or some Parable
distribution is CRV
is
just Ministry the connection that you
could take this example on the right
what would be
in Mississippi
sorry
so maybe you
'll see this
actually this part is yeah almost
yeah just we select randomly functions
and evaluated it but
guarantee so to obtain polynomial
storage we need some trick using some uh
it may be you're interested
sorry was it strong here is there what
people also called proper learning that
what you have put us to be in a certain
class
sorry
we write strong learning in the slide is
there also what people call proper
learning
minus and it's more constant
uh
accuracy
but here we can consider
yeah yeah so it's the standard original
pack definition
as opposed to weak learning which is a
relaxation yes
okay sir and now so let's go back to the
first project so questions
and I explained how to that proof
technique for showing this to them
and the idea to show the
characterization result is to use
dualization and in this work we formally
Define the notion of realization of a
concept class C by uh to easily
computable function G and H looks like
this figure
so the role of one function G is to map
each representation function in the
class
to
some string after and we call this the
Dual of f
and another uh so the role of another
function H is to map each string to
representation of function X and we call
this the Dual of X and contrary to here
is for every function in the class and
for every input the evaluation of this
function is equal to the evaluation of
the Q
this is the construction and the meaning
of easily computable depends on the so
so we try to show and in the case of PPL
design and season this must be a
computable in NCG
um so for example if you have a fixed to
the random generator so we're thinking
of uh to make it a learning problem we
think of the input as a bit position
and so and then the the function is
given by the C
and so now you have like some definition
in the pseudor random generator that
says how do you look up the bits of
which bits of the seed do you access and
then how do you compute the function yes
and all of that is going to be the X
star that says which bits of the of the
seed do you look at and how and how do
you compute the the I bit from this
right yes
okay
maybe uh you no uh yes so that's right I
will explain later yes okay
okay so first of all so let's see the
example for this utilization
oh so let's see the case of the party
edition three but I did really simple so
let's assume that so the representation
is just uh this is at the internal node
and each level and input is X and so for
just so yeah so we can regret this part
as just uh taking uh some inner products
with very trivial very end so yeah we
had one additional list
and then we can regard so by regarding
this representation as input and we can
also regard this x is a representation
of a parity Edition this is very simple
idea to take into a different Edition
trick yeah of course we need to
add some proper pattern to open barric
representation
[Music]
mission three but and this is very rough
explanation you are a big part of this
unit
okay again so the reason why we consider
dividiation okay so first of all in
general
so to connect the notion of running and
the connection notion of cryptography so
we need some kind of duration in the
sense that so in learning the public
information is input to the function
and separate information is functions a
lot of tricycle by contrast in
cryptography the public information
function that tries to compute that
computes a print right function or
pseudonymity or something like that and
secretive information is random input to
the function
and to connect these two Notions we need
to switch the roles of input function
and if we have a
the expressive dualization notion for
concept class I defined in the previous
slide then we can do this switching very
yeah very badly but I think if we have
the addition over Class C we can connect
the hardware address of running C and
pseudonym data computable and see easy
so first I explained the lab idea
outline then I explained the details for
oppialidocious
okay first so let's consider the
direction from harness running a c and a
cylinder
so we can easily sample uh unpredictable
some process in this harness program
then by taking the Dual of this sample
set
we can obtain some pseudo random
generator each object where each input
is changed to with function by taking
drugs and the target function f is
changed to C to this generator and each
output a bit of generator corresponds to
each level
randomness of this generator follows
from the equivalence between
pseudonymity
this is not pseudo random generator
because so this dual of f is not
distributed uniformly in general
but as I've I will explain later how to
change this uh
and I also want to mention that
so this is actually correction of
pseudo-random
because
to over 10 the description of this
generator first we need to select sample
according to this example distribution
and we must select so we must compute
the Dual of the example because like
this it's actually correction
s
and for further uh the other direction
from
objects in C to harness The Branding C
so if we have a pseudo random generator
then by taking the Dual of this we can
obtain against unpredictable sample set
where the target function is a dual of
Random
but so to show how nice of running we
consider uniform distribution over
samples but it gets only
hardness with fixed sample composition
if the learner does not look at the
whole input then we can see the handles
right so it is a how does run with fixed
sample compression so I explained that
how to enhance this to fpt sample
complexity so now I explained the
details
but how to change this to random data is
object to the student number is very
simple so we also contain the random
selection of the function and the
computational Dual as a part of pseudor
and object so we can obtain generator
yeah
something it just run
and by taking enough so large enough
[Music]
observation actually in our case this is
so happy to complex FTD sample
complexity is sufficient in our case so
by taking sufficient to large a sample
complexity we can obtain polynomial
storage
and the complexity to Computing this to
the random generator is just a
so composition of Class C we if you
considerable and the complexity of
computing video and complexity for
sampling function
in our case this is and so we also
consider NC is some proper distribution
so if this part it's nucle then this
must be computable and
okay and if so we have this so okay so
the next problem is how to extend this
result to fix the parameters but the
idea is very simple so just reapply GM
construction and we also use the
Assumption polynomial storage
so
we again again apply the original
generator to enhance the storage of the
generator and if the original generator
is polynomial it's the number of
applications affects exponents
but it also increases the parameter of
for computing pseudonym and by taking
the Dual so it also increases the
parameter for running program then the
learner tries to look at more subjects
but when we consider fpg sample
complexity This increasement only
affects this number of applications only
affect multiple categories so
a number of samples with the runner
required that's why so by taking a less
sufficiently many applications we can
prepare enough sample set to show
harmless run with FPS
with fpt sample complexity and the
existence of Correction of pseudo random
generator
and if we can show the realization of so
that's why if you can show the address
of nuc 0 then we can characterize how so
the existence of Correction ptrs and the
season but by using harderness grinding
and scissors and this seems to be yeah
incorrect conjunction so and actually
unfortunately we cannot hope for
utilization of NCS so we cannot
construct this type of zero so
with preserving evaluation and so this
is because roughly speaking evaluating
uh requires constant number of bits of
big information of the representation F
and we can justify it to verify this by
using the augmented communication
complexity
so to sum up if we have realization of
some Class C we can connect the hardness
of running the C and degrees numbers of
pprd is computable point C
but we cannot hope for join this
offenses then how can we use this idea
to show the equivalent result
the idea is to use transition of super
process of MCL so for now so first let's
forget about an incision and so assume
that so we have some visualization of
superclass organization but because this
class is supercrosive and this is so
filter must be contained in this class
and this part must be mapped to some
subclass of strings
if this subclass is again mapped to
filter
that we can use this direction of
superclass of ncc0 as a kind of
pseudorization organisms and actually in
our case this subclass is a sparse
strangers
so and we Define the notion of the film
transplant condition of dual and so in
the visualization the center part it
will be mapped to some spur stream and
each substance is not to some function
and by using duo with front test pass
condition we characterize ppldt and c0
based on how does run on spots that
sparse distribution because okay so this
is the previous slide and so let's
consider uh how does running on spot let
us then this part is first and by taking
the URL with even transfer solution this
part becomes nc0
filter then we can record so we can
conclude this season of generator in
every season
and if we have sugar endangered
computable and c0 so this part
this part must be yeah and by taking the
Dua with two enters condition so we can
again obtain harness run from sparse
that we can characterize the data design
system by using unless you run on sparse
data
and this idea is meta serum for the
first element
so we Define the notion of SVT dividers
function like this so we have a NCAA
computable functions like that so it
satisfy the condition of uh Duo
and uh every cave Center must be
contained in this uh plus and the Dual
okay
is faster the harming rate is bounded
and uh
for every starting with fixed so so
every is past storing the Dual
sponsoring is careful in this
for example so we can verify that
actually the previous example for
realization Private Edition 3 satisfy
this condition so roughly speaking this
is because so
let's responsible input are the uh
at each so each internal node we only
look at constant number of inputs so
this is
[Music]
distribution over functions
and uh by a yeah verifying so that these
process satisfy the condition this
condition that we can show the first
result thanks in this network and the
importance of this meta theorem is yes
so by using this meta cell you can so we
can reduce the task of characterizing
Correctional pprgs to just study on
representation of Boolean function
because you know Finding uh or verifying
on the representation of Boolean
function s so if you have some your
favorite class and if you can verify
this the weaker so you can solve some
the puzzle problem then we can obtain
dichotomy between
pprd analysis and runability for your
favorite class and actually to show this
you do not need anything about running
okay and in conclusion in this work we
consider dichotomy between learning and
pseudo random data computers
particularly in nc0 and we obtain the
fast characterization for such a classic
and actually this sorry uh followed from
meta seven where we consider the notion
of you are with different transplus
Foundation
then similar so there are several
feature Direction the first one is
finding other characterizations and flow
or other class by using this metal serum
and it is also interesting to
find some other useful some instructions
and by so finding this it might be
possible to characterize this notion by
using other interesting class or example
distribution
thank you very much
[Applause]
questions
so this is getting off topic a bit but
this notion of dual is somewhat
interesting so it seems like one way to
bound the complexity of the Dual problem
is to show that
um the circuit evaluation problem for
the classes in the class itself
because then you can use that for both
the
circuit evaluation is kind of like a
self-dual process
um
but maybe there are some ways of coding
information or we like allowed to recode
how inputs are described and also how
functions are described arbitrarily in
order to lower the cost of circuit
evaluation is is there some
characterization of the complexity of
duals in terms of some form uh
of circuit evaluation
yeah that's very
excellings
oh sorry yeah
and more plus
supposing this is a question just to you
but a question to everyone
this question has been at least that I
know that it's been starting a little
bit like the IPP conjecture with AC zero
on top of the month two hits which is
kind of considered like pre-processing
that but linearly
so specific examples of how to redefine
but wondering if there's like some
generic way of doing it
thank you
let it come in in like 10 minutes